amanda bynes is having a baby I feel I
got what's mine et has learned that the
former child star is pregnant with her
first child
with Paul Michael the man who may or may
not be her fiancee I just wanna let you
know that I love you guys and I'm so
happy now the 33 year old dropped the
baby news on Instagram Tuesday sharing
this pic of a sonogram writing baby on
board Paul hit up social media too
revealing the pregnancy news with the
same ultrasound image as well as a photo
of him and Amanda the same pic that
Amanda posted earlier this week he caps
in the post quote baby in the making but
a few hours later they both deleted
their posts
in a statement to ET Amanda's lawyer
asked for privacy on behalf of his
client who he says is seeking treatment
for ongoing mental health issues quote
any reports that Amanda's suffering from
drug or alcohol addiction issues are
completely false we asked for privacy
during this time and for any speculation
about her personal life from the public
and the media to cease so Amanda can
focus on getting better
sup Instagram just wanted to say hi to
all of my followers I really wanted to
say I appreciate you guys so much for
supporting me the baby news comes just
over a week after it was reported that
Amanda and Paul had called it quits just
three weeks after announcing their
engagement at the time a man to deleted
every pic she had previously posted with
Paul on her insta but just a day later
she had fans very confused when she
posted a new pic with him writing my
love amanda announced her engagement to
Paul on Valentine's Day calling him the
love of my life and she officially
introduced him to her followers just a
few days later who everyone this is Paul
my fiance in February a source told et
that Amanda and Paul met while they were
in the same sober living facility more
than two months ago ivory silver for
overeating sumito et also learned that
Amanda's parents still hadn't met their
daughters 28 year old fiance when he
popped the question
an ET source also pointed out that
because Amanda is under a
conservatorship she can't legally get
married
lest the judge and her conservator her
mom Lynne sign off on the nuptials the
actress has been pretty candid about her
past struggles with drug abuse and
mental health in 2008 teen she talked to
paper magazine about addiction and at
the time she talked about creating a
fashion line but noted she wanted to
return to acting first ETS talked to
some of Amanda's former co-stars about
how she's doing including Nick Cannon
who she started with on all that five
years ago you wrote this open letter to
Amanda Bynes oh yeah I'm the biggest
Amanda Bynes fan like I grew up watching
that girl how do you talk to her as of
recently I haven't but I heard she's
doing so much better and that's I mean
people when they're weird when they're
dealing with personal issues sometimes
you got to give him their space yeah and
then when they reach out then that's the
time to do it so she knows and you know
I always to open invite whenever she
needs anything I'm the career or even
personally I'm here
I would love a comeback everybody wanted
her we trying to get her on wild and I
we had to all that reunion and that's
kind of when I knew like okay she still
was she's still working on herself and
which is an outstanding thing and
Channing Tatum her she's the man co-star
also had something to say I love her I'm
so happy to cease like killing it again
and just back the guy on on the right
like it's she's so talented and so
special and she's been doing it I mean
like I think it's so impossible when you
start at such a young age to keep what
do you remember most about that time and
that experience doing that movie she was
just so alive like I mean when I say
like you never knew what was gonna come
out of her mouth like you she was just
like on fire and that's I don't know I'm
I haven't seen her in so long I hope I
love you man and I hope
[Music]